[electronic music]
- WE MET B-BOY JOSEPH
IN ATLANTA, G.A.
- HI, JOSEPH.
- [British accent]
ALL RIGHT. YEAH.
START THE MUSIC.
[hip-hop music]
♪ ♪
- HAS HE STARTED YET?
- I THINK--
I'M PRETTY SURE THIS IS IT.
♪ ♪
THANK YOU.
- YEAH, THANK YOU.
- I AIN'T DONE YET, THOUGH.
- THANK YOU, JOSEPH.
IT'S--IT'S
DEFINITELY A NO FOR ME.
- IT'S A NO. I'M SORRY.
- NO.
- ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, JOSEPH.
- GUYS, YOU--YOU KNOW,
I AIN'T GOT NO FORMAL TRAININ'
OR NOTHIN' LIKE THAT.
I LIVE ON THE STREETS.
- THAT WAS VERY APPARENT,
AS IT TURNS OUT, JOSEPH.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
- Y-YOU KNOW THAT MY MAMA'S
ON DRUGS, AND MY DADDY IN JAIL.
- IT'S NOT--
NOT REALLY RELEVANT.
- BORN IN A COFFEE CAN
UNDER A BRIDGE.
- THAT'S TERRIBLE, JOSEPH.
THAT'S--THAT'S AWFUL,
BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO--
- MY SISTER SHOT MY BROTHER
WHILE MY COUSIN BEAT MY UNCLE.
- NOW IT'S A LIE.
- IT'S A LITTLE BIT MUCH.
JOSEPH, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, BUT--
- PUT MYSELF THROUGH SCHOOL
BY RENTING MY BODY OUT
AS A HEROIN SUITCASE.
- OH, I SEE WHAT'S GOING ON.
- WOW.
- JOSEPH, PLEASE, WE--WE DO HAVE
OTHER DANCERS HERE TODAY,
WHO ARE WAITING THEIR TURN
VERY POLITELY.
NO, JOSEPH,
LET HER COME ONSTAGE.
- OH! OH!
- LET HER COME--NO, JOSEPH.
- IF I WIN THIS COMPETITION, I
COULD PUT A ROOF OVER MY HOUSE.
'CAUSE I GOT A HOUSE AIN'T
GOT NO ROOF. FOR REAL, THOUGH.
- JOSEPH...
- JUST ONE LITTLE THING,
THOUGH.
- DON'T DO IT, JOSEPH.
- IT WAS A LOUD BRIDGE.
- DON'T FINISH THAT SEN--
- I GOT HEARING DAMAGE
IN THIS EAR.
- JOSEPH!
- AND ALSO IN THIS EAR.
- THE BRIDGE HAD--
HAD TRUCKS GO OVER IT.
- JOSEPH.
- 'CAUSE THE BRIDGE--
- KEEP IT.
- 15-TON--
- HOLD IT.
PUT IT IN YOUR MOUTH.
AND GET OFF MY STAGE.
- RA--RATED SIX.
- JOE...
- THAT'S A BIG TRUCK.
- SEPH.
OKAY, JOSEPH, PLEASE.
AND WHO IS THIS?
- OH, WHO IS THIS
RIGHT HERE?
THIS IS MY 12-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER,
WHO I RAISED ALL BY MYSELF
WITHOUT THE HELP OF ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
SHE IS MY INSPIRATION.
- JOSEPH,
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THERE'S NOTHING
YOU CAN DO OR SAY
THAT'S GOING TO MAKE US
CHANGE OUR MINDS TODAY.
- THAT RIGHT THERE, THAT RIGHT
THERE, THAT'S HER DAUGHTER.
SHE BLIND.
SO I RAISED THEM BOTH BY MYSELF
WITHOUT NOBODY ELSE'S HELP.
- COME GET
YOUR TICKET TO VEGAS.
- WHOO-HOO-HOO-HOO!
- VEGAS!
- CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
I'M GETTING GOOSIES OVER HERE.
I'M GETTING GOOSIES. I-I AM.